incoming 30 years if a young researcher
like me is to get a Nobel Prize for what
do you think it would be it would be for
something that you're passionate for
each year at the lindau meetings in
Germany young researchers come together
to learn from Nobel Prize rates as well
as from each other I work with tiny
marine organisms and look at how fluid
flow affects their dynamics it's
fascinating to see how things that such
tiny scales can have such global
climatic implications I want to cure
malaria and to do this we need early
detection methods and this is an essay
I'm trying to develop currently but
there's much more to the meetings in
lindale and seeking scientific
collaboration they also inspire
discussion about wider questions in
science
the use of genetically modified
organisms in food production has been
the source of many communication
problems for scientists according to one
Nobel laureate one problem is is food
and having enough food there was a
lecture this morning about about GMO how
GMOs should be used and should not be
thwarted in terms of being able to
provide rice that's far more nutritious
to people in Africa for example and that
really could have an impact he used
Golden Rice as an example where they
just engineered this rice to have beta
carotene in the grain of the rice they
were documented evidence that the amount
of this golden rice that you need to
take care of children at an early age
for especially vitamin A deficiency this
it was proposed that it's something like
over some kilograms of them you need to
yeah take care of it but that was a
stupid law but but yeah but as a matter
of fact it just what few hundred grams
hundred and fifty grams that you need so
it's exactly so there is a very
conscious effort to really miss guide
people soon so what about GMOs in Europe
because they're they're abandoned in the
u.s. we have so many chin and this makes
me angry like what makes people fearful
exactly there is nothing to make sure
it's all about so if you ask the general
public do you want GMOs in your food
yeah I'll say no because you might have
biotics in your figure but if you say
what did jmi they'll be like um green
magic something that needs to be labeled
yeah see this is what happens to know
the tix a mess up in there yeah but then
maybe this needs to be ingrained even
from an early stage at school level that
okay these are alternative so that
people need to be educated about see I
think it's a job with scientists to do
that scientists themselves ought to work
to be able to explain their work in an
understandable way to a broad audience
and we also rely on the other media etc
to to publicize work but there's there's
some concerns about that much of the
media today give equal time to a very
valid scientific approach that's been
validated and is correct ninety-nine
percent of the time they give equal time
to that and also to some things that are
completely at odds with the consensus of
science many people all over the world
now and in the United States for example
don't believe in fluoridation even
though it's good worried about vaccines
even though they save lives don't
believe in climate change even though
it's basically happening and so on and
and we have to ask ourselves why do
people have these different points of
view and we have a challenge to explain
that properly we have to keep putting it
out there that's why I tweaked I tweet
so that my information about that things
like this are safe is going into the
public domain and eventually if enough
scientists do that then yeah I think
that there needs to be more scientists
that are vocal about like their research
other people's research just you know
talking about should it be like I am do
you see I don't think it should be
holger either know that like housing you
know there's some science is that a
meditates of patrons or something like
this should actually be a profession
you're a scientist but all you do is PR
work and you but but I don't matter
thank you for another excellent have
communicators in signs up I think not a
scientist who are communicated lindo is
not an ivory tower on the contrary lindo
is paving the way to show how science
can be communicated for a general
benefit and wellbeing for the society I
think we had some very interesting
discussions about how a mutual
interaction and do a lot better to the
society than what we are actually doing
now it's extremely beneficial when we
can apply this to society right just
getting lab results and keeping them
published on a paper or something
doesn't really benefit the community as
a whole and so it's much better if we're
able to communicate what our findings
mean and its implications on society
the beautiful bay above tree or tree of
life is an African I cut the bail Bob
fruit contains four times the potassium
of banana three times the vitamin C of
an orange and twice the calcium of
spinach but the bail Bob is an orphan
science has paid little attention to
this tree until now the African orphan
crops consortium is harnessing the power
of genetics for orphan crops the bail
Bob tree is the first of 101 plants to
have its genome sequence assembled and
annotated and the information will be
made available to all unrestricted where
millions of people are malnourished this
genetic data will help farmers provide
the food they need the genomes will
guide African plant breeders so they can
create crops that are higher yielding
water and nutrient you sufficient
resilient to climate change and full of
nutrition triggering a huge leap forward
for the diversity and sustainability of
the continents agriculture
you